don't push this button
because that will set off the bomb
immediately and we'll all be dead
now repeat back what i just said
i agree no
no that's the button that will kill
everyone try again i am groot mm-hmm
i am groot uh-huh
no
does anybody have any tape out there i
want to put some tape over the death
button nobody has any tape not a single
person has tape you have an atomic bomb
in your bag and if anybody's gonna have
tape it's you i have to do everything
you are wasting a lot of time
[Applause]
that's a really bad sign
this is weird we've got a sovereign
fleet approaching from the rear why
would they do that probably because
rockets stole some of their batteries
dude
right you didn't steal some of those i
don't know why they're after us what a
mystery this is
what were you thinking dude they were
really easy to steal that's your defense
come on you saw how that high priest has
talked down lois now i'm teaching her a
lesson
i didn't realize your motivation was
altruism it's really a shame the
sovereignty mistaken your intentions and
are trying to kill us exactly i was
being sarcastic oh no you're supposed to
use a sarcastic voice now i look foolish
can we put the big green on hold until
after we survive this massive space
battle
coming good i'm gonna kill some guys
the beast highest you think could be
pierced on the outside
i must cut through it from the inside
huh no no
wait a minute
[Music]
[Applause]
what is he doing he said the skin is too
thick to be bearded from the outside but
that doesn't make any sense i try to
skin is the same level of thickness from
the inside is from the outside i realize
that
there's a cut on its neck
rock it get it to look up
[Music]
[Music]
what is this
[Music]
my sister
a hero
a garden of the galaxy guardians of the
galaxy why would we be the gardens of
the galaxy
are you kidding me with family like this
who needs enemies
you people have issues guardians of the
galaxy volume two video pg-13 get
tickets now on fandango just who do you
think
you are
well
rocket yeah
and
me star munch i'm not gonna answer the
star much on may 5th put your seatbelt
on you only get one chance to save the
galaxy twice
oh wow i know that almost hit me
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 rated
pg-13
the sovereign
the ravagers
they all want us dead that's a really
bad sign
the guardians must be destroyed
hit me with your best shot
oh wow i know that almost hit me
get tickets now
the fate of the universe lies in your
shoulders
whatever you do
don't push this button now repeat back
what i just said i am groot uh-huh
i'm cool no
so here we are a thief one thug a green
mean machine a maniac and an angry
little tree
hold on
so we're saving the galaxy again
well who
does anybody have any tape out there i
want to put some tape over the button
nobody has any tape
that's a really bad sign
this film is not yet ready
groot put your seat belt on
spaceship
yes that was awesome
so here we are a thief one thug an
assassin a maniac and an angry little
tree
hold on
oh so we're saving the galaxy again well
who else is going to do it
the guardians cannot protect the galaxy
from us
there must be some kind of peaceful
resolution to this
or even a violent one where i'm standing
over there
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 get
tickets now for realty and imax 3d
there's a thousand of them
and five of us
these odds are terrible
we need new odds what
on may 5th
you only get one chance to save the
galaxy
twice here you stand
a hero
a garden of the galaxy guardians of the
galaxy why would we be the gardens of
the galaxy oh i'm so stupid
i hope you're ready it'll be here any
minute
is that a rifle you don't know what a
rifle looks like
it's just swords were your thing and
guns were mine but i guess we were both
doing guns now i just didn't know that
well that's intense
i see it within you
fear
jealousy
betrayal
it is our duty
to cleanse the universe of this weakness
you know they told me you people were
conceited douchebags but that isn't true
at all
dude ah i'm using my wrong eye
put your seatbelt on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're saving the galaxy again
yep
awesome
we're really gonna be able to jack up
our prices for two-time galaxy savers
[Music]
[Applause]
sometimes the thing you're searching for
your whole life
is right there by your side all wrong
you're right
all you do is yell at each other you are
not friends
no
we're family
who said maybe her
hope you're ready it'll be here any
minute
is that a rifle you don't know what a
rifle looks like
it's just swords were your thing and
guns were mine but i guess we're both
doing guns now i just didn't know that
well that's intense
i see it within you
fear
jealousy
betrayal
it is our duty to cleanse the universe
of this weakness
you know they told me you people were
conceited douchebags but that isn't true
at all
dude ah i'm using my wrong eye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're saving the galaxy again yep
awesome
we're really gonna be able to jack up
our prices for two-time galaxy savers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sometimes the thing you're searching for
your whole life
is right there by your side all along
you're right
all you do is yell at each other you're
not friends
no
we're family
who said maybe her
after all these years i've found you
and who the hell are you
i'm your dad peter
[Music]
so we're saving the galaxy again
who else is gonna do it
awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
just who
in the hell do you think you are
well
[Music]
that was awesome
he's so cute
i'm good
what's that he says welcome to the
frickin guardians of the galaxy
only he didn't use fricken
look out oh wow
i tried guys
[Music]
[Music]
the fate of the universe lies on your
shoulders
now whatever you do
don't push this button
because that will set off the bomb
immediately and we'll all be dead
now repeat back what i just said
i agree no
no that's the button that will kill
everyone
try again i am groot mm-hmm
i am groot uh-huh
i'm true no
showtime a-holes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
does anybody have any tape out there i
want to put some tape over the death
button nobody has any tape not a single
person has tape you have an atomic bomb
in your bag and if anybody's gonna have
tape it's you i have to do everything
you are wasting a lot of time
[Applause]
that's a really bad sign
if i touch someone i can feel their
feelings
you feel
love yeah i guess yeah i feel a general
unselfish love for just about everything
no
sexual though no no i don't know
she just told everyone your deepest
darkest secret dude come on i think
you're overreacting a little bit you
must be so embarrassed
to me don't mean to me
[Music]
raise your hand if you know what this is
you should have thought this through uh
i can't see if you're raising your hand
several hundred years ago long before
you were born this was invented this
simply has one function and it is to
play music there's no touch screen
there's no streaming you listen to a
tape you started at the beginning you
ended at the end you couldn't hit
shuffle you couldn't skip back and forth
you couldn't hit repeat you listened to
a tape as if you were sitting at a
concert but all
in the ease
and comfort
of a walk so they call it a walkman did
you put on your head
and you can walk man
just who do you think
you are
well
and
me star munch i'm not gonna answer the
star much on may 5th put your seatbelt
on
you only get one chance to save the
galaxy twice
oh wow i know that almost hit me
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 rated
pg-13
push this button
because that will set off the bomb
immediately and we'll all be dead
now repeat back what i just said
no now that's the button that will kill
everyone
try again i am groot mm-hmm
i am groot uh-huh
[Music]
showtime a-holes
screw you spaceship
[Music]
does anybody have any paper out there i
want to put some tape over the death
button nobody has any tape not a single
person has tape i have to do everything
you are wasting a lot of time
[Applause]
that's a really bad sign
you